では よろしくお願いします
これから今日の話 テーマに入ります
こちらには見えませんだけど
まあそちら見えますかね
スクリーンは あの今日はこの
えーとえーと まあ誤解と理解の瀬戸際でということで
コミュニケーションというコミュニケーションの実態なんですね
本当に見えません [笑い]あ
そこからそこは私見えません
他のマイクロフォンを持ってきて
そんなところに で あの
何でしたっけ？給援艇という理論でまあ考えてみるということで
あの そういうことにします
コミュニケーションというのは
まあどちらかというと給援艇ということなんですね
この給援艇っていうのは
まあまあ論理的に考えると
まあ A が B に Z というものを与えるということにしますね B
が Z を受け取る ならば問題はありません
コミュニケーションっていうのはそういうもので
何か何かに誰かに与えるものは
それをその通りに受け取るならば
まあ結構ということで
それで一  B が Z を一必要としないので受け取れない
問題はもう B さんの方にな
そんなことは で あの それは一で
二は Z を大嫌いなので
目の前で Z を壊すんですね
こんなのはいらない 要りませんと
目の前で壊す コミュニケーションの場合は
相手が言ったことをすぐ真っ向から反対して
こうなってグズグズでもう非難してね
かなり攻撃するということになるんです
で  3番目 Z の使い方がわからないので壊れる
変化する  受け取ったのは受け取ったんだけど
あまりもうどうやってどうなのの通りわからないで
まあもう受けたものは壊れてしまうんですね
これもよくあることで
人が言うことは我々はまあなんかその通りには理解しない
まあいろいろ 4番目は Z を受け取るが
本来の目的  B が期待したこと
目的ですね と違う もう間違いいっぱいあると思います
今日は 違ったことに利用するんです
ちょっと随分午後も早く焦って作りましたので
打ち間違いはいっぱいあります
先生 こっちに  あ？ こっちに来てください
こちら  こちらで 真横  ん？ 真横
真横に  で あの 自分は話してないのでね
こういう [笑い]選び方はよくないですね
ここ置けないの？ここに
ん？ ここに置けないです
テーブルがない  ここそばで見えなすぎですかね
これ これ  まあとにかく 4つのスタンスがございまして
一応考えてください あの
そのまま受け取る場合と
もう全く受け取らない場合
あるいは破壊する場合とかね
まあいろいろあります
それで この牛丸系の世界と同じく
このコミュニケーションっていうのが意見の交換ということでね
同じことが起こるんですね
素直に自分の意見を理解するならば
問題はないんです 私が言いたいことは素直に理解していただければ
全然問題はありません
しかし 自分の意見が必要としないので聞かない
理解しない 無視する だいたい世の中で私たちはいろんなことを喋りますけど
相手がもう全然もうそんなのいらんやと
あなたの話なんか聞きたいもないという状態を取るんですね
で もう強引に聞かされてももう理解もしない
理解しようともしないということもあります
で 相手が違う 違った意見を持っていて
自分の意見に真っ向から反対する批判する
2番目のケースは 私が言うことと
相手がまたまるっきり違う意見を持っていて
お互いものすごくもうぶつかり合ってケンカになるんですね
だからそちらでもコミュニケーションは成り立ってないんですね
3番目はよく理解できなくて間違ったりする
反対というわけじゃなくて
言うことはあんまりよく理解できない
よくわからない あるいはもう
こういうことではないかというふうに自分勝手に判断したりして
それで言いたいことと違ったものを理解してしまうんですね
4番目は自分が言ったことと関係のない理解
誤解するんですね で それは前の 4つに合わせますから
あの 間違ってるというよりも
全くもう違うことになってしまうんですね
誤解するんですね これらは逆さまに理解するってよくあることなんですよ
で 私たちも誤解 我々はコミュニケーションの問題でもまず誤解していることがあるんですよ
頭の中で何でも理解できると思っていることは誤解です
人間の頭で 生命の頭でもどちらでもいいんですけど
もう何でも理解できるんだよと思ったところがちょっと大きな間違いなんですね
理解できないことっていうのはよくありますよ
だからもっともっとこれを派手に理解してほしいんだから
私はこの例え出してあると思いますね
有名な例にたとえ例えたのはそういうためなんです
我々あげるものは何でも受け取るっていうことはちょっとありえないんですよ
だからコミュニケーションの場合は
自分が言うことは何でも理解できるぞと思ったら
まあそれはちょっと成り立たないですね
私の人がいくら飼い慣れているといっても
虎をくれても受け取れないんですよ
例えばものすごい飼い慣れてる虎がいますよ
あんたもらってください
もらってくださいって
もらうわけいきませんでしょう
だから怖くないんだよとね
もう赤ちゃんの時からもう小指で育てたものだからね
猫よりも可愛いんだよ
そんなこと何言われたっても
虎を受け取るわけにはいきませんね
そんなところで飼うもしょうがないし
まあ困ったりするし だからくれるものなら何でも
なんでもちょうだいっていうことは成り立たないんです
あげてるんだだから取ってくださいよと
何をどうかっていうことは世の中であいつがないんですね
だから 物で考えれば コミュニケーションの場合はデータの場合も同じことなんです
私が言ってるんだから理解しなさいということは決して成り立たない
理解できないものもありますよ
虎を変えないでしょうに
ちょっとおっかないんですよ
まだ法律的には禁止でいるんですね
だからもうどうにもならんね
その場合は 相手に要求があって
また自分にそれがある時のみ
自分が言うことを相手が理解するのです
これはまた牛眼点でよくわかることなんですよ
人がお腹が空いていて
まあご飯食べたいと思っている時は
まあはい どうぞと 弁当ありますからと言うとお互いまあもううまくいきますよ
ちょうどよかったということになるんです
だから 正しくコミュニケーション付き合いたいと理解してもらいたいならば
この条件でなければ成り立ちません
相手が聞きたいことがあるして
私も見事にちょうどそのことが言うならば
もうぴったし理解するんですよ
それ以外は理解はしません
はい それで一つのセクションが終わりました
コミュニケーションというのはそういうものなんですね
ほぼ理解しない お互いお互いに理解しない世界なんです
だからコミュニケーションというのはミスコミュニケーションなんですね
いわゆるもう連絡取れないことが連絡を取ることになっているわけです
理解不可能なことが理解することに世の中はできているのです
だから結局はコミュニケーション成り立つのはぴったし
牛眼点が合う時なんですね
それ以外はもうあまりもういろいろ問題が起こるのです
ガタガタになります はい
そこは次のセクション
コミュニケーションというのは頭で理解することだから
この頭というか心というかね
そういうものについてもうちょこっと考えた方がよろしいと思います
頭の中には何が入っているのかと
で このポイントっていうのは
仏教はそんなにややこしく分析しません
まあ大体もう頭の中で何か考え方がね
しがみすぎている場合は
他の意見は入らなくなりますよ
だから意見に何かにしがみつくこと自体が人間にとってとても不幸なことであると
成長はそれでストップするんですね
だから仏教のこの邪見と言いますが
我々は色々な意見を知ったものにはすごくしがみつく
執着するのです もうこれで終わりですよ
もうそれからもう何も言っても言っても言っても頭に入らなくなるんです
理解しなくなっちゃうんですね
だからその上コミュニケーションなんだらかんだって言ったって話にならないんです
そういうわけで 仏教は一般的な結論としていうのは
コミュニケーションしたければ
自分が何かの意見に いろいろものに執着してはならないと
何かに執着して 何かの考え方を持っていると
その角度でしか世の中は見えないんです
だから二度とは話せませんよ
それで我々の心の中を見ると
自分が自分なりにいろんな生き方
いろんな考え方いっぱい持ってるんです
持ってるならば もう世間とはもう切断状態なんです
電波が届かないとと思うところへよ
だからこのコミュニケーションという問題は
仏教から見ればそう簡単で楽なものではございません
大変なことになります
じゃあ頭の中身は何なのかで
第一は感情ですね 決して頭は事実で満たしているわけではありません
我々の頭はね あらゆる科学データとかね
心理事実でいっぱいっていうことは全くないんです
1 感情は土台にしているんです
我々はものを理解する時の基準
土台は感情なんです 感情は生命共通なので
動物にもあります 感情で物事を理解するんだから
動物も感情はあるんだから
逆に言えば動物とのコミュニケーションはできる
実際は人間同士でのコミュニケーションは不可能な状態でいるんです
しかし 論理的に言えば
動物ともコミュニケーションできるはずなんです
感情っていうのは共通なんです
互いに絡み合って激しい波を立てるので
頭の大半は感情で埋め尽くしてるんですね
頭結構いっぱいです 余裕がありません
あの現代のパソコンでもね
ハードディスクはデータがいっぱいになってくると
まあなかなか機能しないんですね
で 人の話は好きか嫌いかという基準で受け取るんです
それで感情で理解する
感情っていうのはもうそんなに難しくなく
すごい単純です 好きか嫌いか
だから我々は受け取る情報は
その好きか嫌いかで判断して受けたりするわけです
じゃあちょっと余談になりますけど
あの あの なんかあの頭の脳の病気がありまして
脳の一部が壊れると この言語が消えちゃうという病気があるんですね
一切の単語が頭からもう消えてしまうんです
脳のそういうセクションが
あの機能しなくなるんです
まだ復活はできません
脳が壊れたら そこで今までペラペラペラペラ喋っていた人であっても
もしその脳にその異常が起きたら
それっきり一言葉もわからなくなる
頭の中はもう言語一切なし
それでその最近読んだ本なんですけど
その本でこのお医者さんが
この そういう患者さんがいる病棟で大統領の話
テレビで流れるんだから
アメリカで みんなこの話を待ち構えてて
このもう見ているんだ
しかし みんなもう笑ったり怒ったり
ものすごく無関心になったり
嫌な気分になったりするんだ
それでも大統領の話を聞いてるんですね
聞いてるんだけど 単語 1個も理解しない
例えば大統領がレディー・ガガなんて言ったっても
全然それわからない なので
よくもう 笑ったりする
で 何がわかったのか こちら聞いたっても言葉わからないんです
もう脳がそこら死んでるんです
それでもう一人が逆にこの気持ちのところが壊れちゃって
これ女性なんですけど
言語だけ残ってるんです
だから彼女にとっては
今日は寒いですねって言われたっても
我々理解するように理解できないんです
寒いっていうことは 事象の意味で
ああ 温度が下がっているという風に理解する
じゃあ そこでもう彼女に言語を知ってますからね
まあしゃべったらもう全く文法的に言葉分析して
あの あまり言葉を美しく使ってないんだとかね
で 間違いもあるんだとか
なぜならば アメリカンというのは砕けた英語をたくさん喋ります
アメリカンスラングというね
まあ特別に英語の使い方ありますから
もう彼女の頭ではそれは理解できないんです
例えば もうこれってとんでもない邪魔なもの
もう本当に嫌なものはストリングスという英語で言えるんですよ
スティンクって臭いということなんですけど
彼女にとっては臭いは臭いという意味であって
なんかちょっと怪しいという意味で取れないんです
だから日本語でまあちょっと臭うなというと
ただ臭うって意味じゃないんでしょ
別の意味なんです しかし
彼女の病気で臭いでは臭いであって
別の意味は引き取らない
それでこの人間二人グループ二人の差は何なのかと
このお医者さんが分析するんですよ
だから結局は大統領の話はわかったと
一言もわからない人々
そこでこの脳の言語のセクションが死んじゃうと
研究者いうのは ああいう人々は犬になるんだと
犬ですと そう言われると患者さんに親戚に怒られるかもしれませんだけど
学者から研究者から見れば犬ですと
で 人の話はわかるんだと
しかし 言葉がわからないんだと
この口で喋ると我々は感情が絡んでるんですよ
だから感情は読めとれるんです
だからこの決してこのオーティスという病気にかかった人には
嘘はつけません 言語を使うならば嘘を言えますよと
そういう人々は言語はないんだから
愚痴で言うことは理解もしない
その代わりにこの人は嘘をついているのか
すぐわかる それで感情の微妙な変化までよくわかるんだ
だから犬です 犬に嘘はつけません
で 犬が変わっておくと
この他の人間というのは信頼できるかできないかってのは犬がよくわかるんですよ
だから私もすごいびっくりするんですね
よく人の心の底までわかっているって
そこで私たちは言葉であらゆるもうね
ごまかしをしたり 敬語を使ったり
挨拶をしたり いろんな決まり文句をダラダラダラダラダラダラもう流し込んだりして
会話しているつもりなんですけど
まあ時々私の恋のお隣にいるだけでも
誰かが来て すごい丁寧に私を褒めて褒めて
もうおだててしゃべってるんで
犬がもうね その牙をだって大声で出ている
あの人がもうもう回ぐらいあらゆる方法して
まず私に礼をしようと挨拶しようと思ったんだけど
やらせなかったというのは
ちょっと体を触ろうと思った途端
もう飛びかかって それで私は犬をぎっと捕まえておいたんですね
もうそれでもできないから
もう私もうプッっともうもう離しても吠える
だからもうよきよく見ると
やっぱりもう何か腹の中であって
あんまりもう丁寧にっていうことじゃないんですね
これ 小さな子供で何か企んでくると
もう犬に吠えられる 追い出される
何も企むこともなく 何のことなくゴソゴソと来て遊んでると全く平気
それで踏まれなくても全然気にもしない
時々子供も犬を捕まって背中に乗ったり
いろんなことをやってますけど
平気で犬です そういう時
同じ子供何か企んでくる時もあります
その時はもうダメ もう追い出すんですね
だから私はベシベシ追うぐらいのことはもういいんじゃないかと思ってますけど
犬はダメなんですね やっぱり
そういうことで この言葉がないからこそ
見事なコミュニケーションというか
コミュニケーションですかね
あれは 相手が何考えてるかってことだけは理解できる
そういうことで このだからこの動物との対話
コミュニケーションはできます
この感情っていうことはどういうものかと理解しているならば
一 好きの場合は情報をそのまま受け取ることも
好きで判断すると はいはいどうぞと言っていることはそのまま受け取る
に 自分勝手に解釈したり変えたりすることもあります
好きだから自分良い情報を改変するんですね
まあよくね 雑誌 新聞 あちこちで記事とかあるでしょ
本当に情報ないんですよ
なんとかちらっとしたことで
この噂ばっかり書いてるね
このもうもういろんな雑誌いっぱいあるでしょ
まあちょっとなんかちょっとしたことがあっただけで
かなり派手にもう新聞記事を書く
最近思い出すのは あのお相撲さんのなんとかと八百長という話で
で 裁判までかけている
だから記事自体はもうもう裁判官が審判するよりももう明確にもう書くんですね
何やこれと やっぱり裁判所もすごい苦労しますから
もうもう有罪か無罪かで決めるために
こういう新聞記事は何のこともなく
もう有罪ですね 十分データがあると偉そうなこと言うんですけど
裁判官にとってデータがないんですね
一つ そういうことで このそれ好きということで行く場合は
もうほんのわずかなデータでも
自分好き勝手で解釈して
ああ よくわかりましたといったことはと言ったりするのですね
3番目 好きが強い感情になると
それで頭が満杯になる
外の情報は入る余地はありません
そこで感情の場合は 好きっていうことはどんどんどんどんどんどん強くなっちゃうと
それで頭いっぱい もう情報は入りません
結局はコミュニケーションはもう途絶えてしまいそうです
だから感情で我々コミュニケーションするが
感情がそのコミュニケーションを切ったりすることの不可能にすることをします
で これが大きな問題で
第3の問題ですよ 我々はこの欲だけで頭の中でものすごい妄想ばっかり回転させたって
人の話は聞かない 特に若い子なんか恋しちゃうとそれはダメやで
女の例えばもう二十歳の女の子がもうもう四十五歳から六十歳のおじいさんとに恋に落ちますから
できればやめさせてみてください
全く無理なんです 鬼のようにもう攻撃するんですね
もう今まで遊んでいた女の子
ちっちゃな女の子が で
まあ怖い その時何も入りませんね
頭に しかし 大人から見ればもう心配で心配でしょうがないんですね
大人もまあたまたまそういう気になったっていうのはね
ちょっと気をつけろよと
ちょっと落ち着けと あまり真面目に取るなよということを言いたいだけの話ですけど
それはもう聞かない  ですから
このそれは女性だけじゃなくて
男性にもよくある病気で
もう自分の頭の中で妄想の中の世界に閉じ込まれて
社会との関係はもう切断してしまいますね
だからまあ感情で知ることにする
コミュニケーションの取っ手です
好き嫌い その感情がちょっと上がったらもう終わりということ
それで切り離してつなげてたんですけど
あの1嫌いの場合とで好きで情報キープ
2番目嫌い 嫌いの場合は情報をそのまま受けて嫌いにの栄養にするんですね
まあ嫌いなことを自分に嫌な人の話なんかね
聞くとすごく聞くんですよ
あんた知ってますか？あの人はね
この前でこういうことをしましたと
自分もそれだとすごく嫌いなんですね
そうすると そのまま ああ
そうですか そうですかと言って
あの嫌いな感情をますます増やしちゃうんですよ
危ないんですよ それで頭いっぱいになりますからね
例えば 男と女が仲良くしていて
まあ男が女がこの人はもう嫌になっちゃって
もうもうもう別れたい
別れたいと言うと もうその自分には嫌な気持ちがあって
誰かが友達が嘘でもいいんですよ
丸っきり関係ない嘘でも
あいつはね 信頼できんだからね
ちょっと優柔不断って一言だけでもう乗っていくんで
ああ そうですか そうなんですよ
私もそう思っていたんだよと
やっぱり それで嫌な気持ちがもう確定したんで
そこで相手にあなたは優柔不断で
信頼できなくて だらしなくて
頼らなくて あれ なんのことかオンですよ
ならない 今まですごい助けてあげたのにということになって
だからこの嫌いな尺度で物事を判断すると
大体言ってること聞くんですよ
聞いたっても 結果はそんな結果になるんです
で 自分の解釈 解説ですか
解釈を入れて情報を変えて理解するわけです
次に何するのかというと
自分で解釈するんですね
例えば 日本の方々はもう北朝鮮から来る情報
何であろうとも 北朝鮮のこと嫌いだからね
むちゃくちゃ解釈する
全部解釈はもう嫌いということはもう応援するだけです
だからそういうことっていうのは
日常世界で我々はもうよく起こる
よくするんですね  3嫌いの感情が強化して頭いっぱいになり
情報が入る余地がなくなる
3番目はもうどんどん感情情報を入れるたびに感情が高ぶっていくんだから
やがて頭がいっぱいになって
もうディスクは動かなくなるんです
そう データが入らない
そういうコンピューターは終わり
もう機能しないということになります
この場合も 3の問題ですよ
なぜならば この精神的にイカれて社会で問題を起こすのは
社会が悪だからじゃない
秋葉原で人を殺した人は
もう秋葉原に来る人々が悪いんだからじゃない
誰の彼になんの悪いことをしたわけではない
誰か嫌な人がいたならば
その人を狙って殺すならば
これ理解できますよ これ長い間のお互いの憎しみ合いあった結果よ
それは全くなし 自分だけの頭の中で感情を引き起こして
引き起こして引き起こして一杯
もうパンク状態 もう消渋不可能
爆発するしかないです
はい それで結論 成立しないコミュニケーション
情報を感情の上に刷り込むものです
入る情報っていうのは感情の上に刷り込むでしょ
感情は生命共通ですが
個人によって強弱の差があります
まあ感情といっても欲と怒りと無知ですよ
これはどんな生命にも共通ですが
強弱は個人個人にとって違います
絡み合ったり 自動発生したりします
感情っていうのは絡むんですね
もう無知と大体欲からも無知と怒りが当然絡み合うし
時々もう怒りと欲が両立して
もうお互い影響を受けて成長するし
あらゆる働きがありますよ
感情の働き で これはまあ
仏教の心理学では学ぶしかないんです
例えば 欲と怒りは同じ時間で心には生まれません
しかし この電波と同じく
欲が怒りを育てることがあります
怒りが欲を育てることがあります
それはあの あの 何といいますかね
この電気の場合は この今の充電機器でも
あの何もコンセント何も繋げなくて
そこに置いただけで充電する場合あるでしょ
いろいろ今 日常使う器具になりますよ
前は何かにぎゅっとさせなくちゃいけなかったんですよ
今はそうじゃなくて 充電器の上に置いておくだけ
置いておけば もう何のことなくもう充電してるんです
あれはそばに充電機器に電気流れてますから
このマグネティックフィールドというね
磁場ができまして この磁場のところにこの充電するものを置いておけば
もう電気が生まれるんです
そんな感じで 例えば皆様
夏になってくるとどうしてもかき氷食べたくなりますでしょ
もう寒くなってくるともう何食べたくなって
なんでしょう 鍋食べたくなっちゃうんですね
正反対でしょ もう寒い時はもう寒いことを楽しめばいいのに
それと全く違うこと じゃあ鍋でも食べようかなと
で 冬は暑いんだから暑さを楽しめばいいのに
じゃなくて かき氷でも食べようかなという
しかし もうかき氷と夏っていうのは全く正反対なんですよ
性質は そういうことで
感情っていうのは互いにこの逆影響を受けて膨張する場合もあります
それで何になるかというと
感情っていうのはいつでも変わるんです
もうものすごく もうあまりにも激しく変わる
人間の性格っていうのは感情
気持ちのことなんですよ
だからもう朝 朝の気持ちと昼の気持ちはものすごく違いますよ
雨が降っている時の気分と晴れの時の気分っていうのはえらく違うんです
ちょっと化粧しただけで
服を着替えただけで もう自分が変わっているんです
別人になっている そういうことですよ
だから感情の上にコミュニケーションを取らなくちゃいけないんですよ
入る情報も すでに入ったものも
その感情によって理解が変化しているわけです
だからどう喋ればいいかとさっぱりわからないんです
その時その あ この人今気分が良さそうだから
じゃあ喋ってやろうかなと思って喋ると
もうあっという間に気分が悪くなって嫌だとか何とか言うかもしれません
そうするともう喋らなくなっちゃう
だから大変ですよ では
もうとにかく話し合いましょうと言って
お互いもう決めて座って話し合いをし
そうそうしても もうものすごく瞬間に相手の気持ちが変わるのだから
気持ちが変わったら もうデータがデータの入り入り方が変わる
そこでかつて学んだものであっても
前に理解していたものであっても
後になったらダメですと言うでしょ
そういう経験があるんじゃないでしょうかね
いいと決めたのに 後になってダメですと断ります
これなんのことか だからでしょ
みんな約束は文章で書いておく
まあ気持ちはやっぱり変わってますけど
その時まずその時まずいことをしましたね
私はこの文章で書かなかった方が良かったのにとか
この間の土曜日  NHK で笑い番組がありまして
この法律相談 何でも相談してあげるという番組で
何も相談してくれませんけれど
答えくれませんだけど
1つの質問は ある男がもうだらしなくて
もうグリーンばっかしやっていて
女がずっと我慢して それで男の人は
じゃああんたに家あげますから離婚しましょう
といったら 本人もまあもう家くれるんだったらね
まあいいやと で 離婚も決まって
後で家あげませんよ その代わりに 300 万あげますと
当然気持ちが変わったと
では 問題はもう本人には家ありますということは
変える変えることはできますか？と
奥さんは 300 万は要りません
家が欲しいと だから奥さんは 300 万ではなくて家をもらえますかと
法律はどうなっているのかと
そこで何人かタレントさんが言ったのは
やっぱり文章にした方が良かったんでは
文章にしなかったんだから
口約束は成り立ちませんだからもらえませんよと
で 法律ではもらえますよという答えでしたけど
やっぱり弁護士に言ったら
やっぱりまあ文章にした方がどちらもよろしいと
で そこで私は何を理解したかというと
やっぱり人の理解というのもそんなもんなんです
初めはこの女からとにかく離れたいと
この女は全然離婚承諾しないんだと
まあどうでもいい家あげると
家あげたら離婚 離婚承諾してくれるんでしょうと思って
それで見事に承諾してこれた
次に感情が変わって なんでこの女に家をあげるんですかと
それも俺のものにとってやるそうで
これまた気持ちが変わってくる
そういうことだから この人間が感情で理解するし
感情っていうのは恐ろしく変化する
全く当てにならないっていうことです
ですから コミュニケーションっていうのは成り立たないんです
はい  2番目 頭の中の情報
事実というものでいっぱいと思っているでしょ？どうでしょうかね
我々の頭の中でいろいろ情報がありますかね
我々は様々な情報 知識を蓄積します
しかし それで客観的に事実を知ることにはならないんです
いくつかの情報は知ってますけど
あまり知識人にはならない
情報を受ける場合 何でもどうぞということにはなりません
我々は勉強するときでも
じゃあ何でもいいよ 勉強してやるぞとはありえませんね
個人の頭に個人が頭にフィルターをかけるんです
データを受けての場合
我々はフィルターをつけるんです
知識なら何でもいいやということはちょっと成り立たない
心には理解可能の範囲があるので
センサーが必要です 俺
何でも知り得るわけじゃないんです
あれ 単純な感情 欲望だけ
何でも知りたいんだ しかし
頭にはもう能力に限りがあります
この何で人間アホかと私も考えますけど
この世の中で無限というものはないんです
この科学者だけですよ
何でも無限にあるんだよと言ってる
私も子供の頃 この地球の酸素なんかはもういくらでもあります
これはもういくらたってももう減りません
だから科学者には何でも永遠で
資源は無限で 化石燃料もいくらでもあって
絶対尽きませんよ という世界で皆様は生きているんです
だから皆様からから見れば
私はもう相当のアホでしょうね
もう何でももうキリがないと言っているんだから
だからこの世の中はそう思ってますけど
目から見れば それ無限に
無料にあるっていうことは
話自体がおかしいんです
無限無料っていうのは論理的に成り立つのであって
それもこの心の機能と時間という観念だけなんです
それも証明できません
理論です 論理的に証明できます
できるだけで 実際はできません
証拠を取って出すのは
だから我々の心も 一個なくなったら
すぐその心が生まれる
なんで次の心生まれるかというと
前の心死んだっていう原因なんです
そうなってくると 心の流れがいきなり無限になる
心が瞬間死んだ理由で次の心が生まれる
今もそうなんです ずっと
自分の心っていうのは生滅でしています
だから滅したらその理由で生じるならば
どうしますか？生じたものはすぐ滅するんです
滅した理由でまた生じる
生じた理由で滅するんです
そうすると無限になりますよ
例えば Aの次 Bが必ず生まれますよという組織を作ります
これ Bの次はAが生まれます A
があったら次にBがあります
必ず Bがあると次にAがあります
必ず生まれます そうすると
どれぐらいこの鎖が延び延びます？無限ですよ
どうしようもない Aが現れると
もうBがもう起こらざるを得られません
起こります  Bが起こると
もう次にAがどうしても起こります
そうなってくると 無限というものは論理的に成立します
で これは論理です  仏教でいうにはそういうことでありますので理解してください
人間は無限にあると証明
どうやって証明します？無限というそのものも証明できないんだからね
だから 世の中はもう何でも無限無量であってほしいでしょ
皆様は金でもね 無限にあってほしいでしょうと思っているでしょう
何年ぐらい生きているつもりですかと言ったら
これ無限でしょうね 気持ちだけは絶対死にたくはないんです
しかし 実際はそうじゃない
もうエネルギーはキリがないんです
この肉体はもう支える
そこでギリギリっていうアクロピッってものあるんです
そういうわけでね 理解能力でしたってもキリがあります
何でも理解できるってことなんです
そういうわけで 生命たるものが一切でもものを知る場合はフィルターかけてます
自我愛 生存欲 死 苦を避けたいという本能でフィルターができる
このフィルターが何なのかというと
自我愛なんです あるいは生存欲なんです
生き続けたいという欲
それがフィルターなんです
あるいは死にたくない
苦しみ 苦しみたくないという気持ち
それも本能なんです これでフィルタリングして情報を受け取る
よりわかりました 結論は
我々は自我愛を肯定するものしか理解しないんです
我々はこの生存欲を応援するものしか理解しないんです
それから 死を乗り越えられるとかね
言えばすぐ乗っていくんです
その話には どんなものもさせます
あんた なんだらかんだらの聖域の砂を食べれば
もう不老長寿になります
言っちゃうと もう食っちゃいますよ
大丈夫 何でもやります
それぐらい我々は情報を入れる場合は
例えばもうもう本当に笑っちゃいますけど
バナナダイエットの次に今キウイダイエットになってるんだと
よくも神様 女の方向を作る場合はね
脳細胞を取り除いて作ったもんだな
脳もひと欠けらもなく
よく生きてることと思いますけどね
だからこの単純な生存欲でしょうに
いかに馬鹿にされているかと
気づきもしないでしょう
痩せるものなら何でもやると
だからそういうのは苦を乗り越えることで
太ったら苦しいと かっこ悪いと
もう可愛くないんだと
セクシーでなくなっちゃいますよ
まあ私みたいにね まあ膝が痛いんだからね
長時間立っていられないんだから
もう痩せたい 痩せたい
体重を減らしたいと思っても
それはすごい論理的な
皆様 動けなくてセクシーでなくなるんだから
美しさはなくなるんだから
美声ってのはないんです
そういうことで 我々のこのフィルタリングはそれでできています
だからコミュニケーション取られてると思ったら
それ勘違いですよ 皆様にも
どんな生命にも 自分の自我愛を肯定することしか聞こえません
まあ例えばこの生物の分析とかなんとかとか
いくら言ってもそれは理解しません
しかし どこかの深海にあるなんとかサメの脂が
南極にありますけど あの寒さでも凍りませんだから脂が脂肪
それが体にとてもいいんだよと
これで心臓がもう血液がサラサラ流れますよと
まあコレステロールは減りますよ
あれやこれやと言うと
まあそれは覚えておいて
私も覚えておいて サメの名前は忘れて
私さえも 人を馬鹿にしようと思って読んでみたんだけど
聞いてみたんだけど 結局自分も同じことで
このサメの脂であのもうあれこれになるんだという
この自分の都合のいいところだけ覚えちゃった
そんなもんでしょ 人間っていうのは
だから私が言いたかったのは
誰の油を食っても 誰の肉を食っても体は消化しますよと
体を消化して 体にに必要なものしか受け取りませんよと
サメの油を注入したら死にます
それはお腹で消化して分解して
自分の体に適したもので受け取るんですよ
だからお医者さんなんといえども
コレステロール高いの高い人は
どんなサメの油を食べても
どんな高級のオリーブオイル食ってもコレステロールなるんですよ
気をつけてください で
オリーブオイルにはコレステロールは全くないんだと
アンセチュレードファットしか何もないんだと
と言ったっても セチュレートファット作る体では作るんです
工場は自分の体の工場だからね
データがどうであってもいいんです
しかし 私たちは何か学ぶ場合は
どうも自分の都合でっていうか
この生存欲を 応援するものしか頭に入らないんです
覚えられないんですよ
他のものは 聞いても聞いてすぐ忘れます
あのカビアってどんな魚の卵でしたっけ？それは覚えてますね
で あの川魚 海の魚 ん？これはそれ知らない
というか 高いですね 川魚ですけど
あの だけど そこであの都合の良いところは
もう食べたことないかもしれませんけど
あの 何でしたっけ？カビアってのは高級というものであると
金持ちが食べると羨ましいなという自分の生存欲が働いて
それを覚えさせたんです
他 大事なことは極々何年なんかすぐ忘れて
で そういうことで 我々の頭にフィルター
フィルターがつけている
ついていると そのフィルターが通るもの以外理解しないということを覚えておいて
我々の生きる作業においては
必ずしも自害 生存欲 苦を避けることなどは成功しないんです
ということは 私が知っているものはすべて自害のために
私が知っているものはすべて生存欲のために
生存するために 私が知っているものはすべて死を避けるために
私は知っているものはすべて病気にならないためなんですが
誰も成功したことはないでしょう
誰も成功したことはないんです
成功のところか あまりにも健康で長生きしたと思っちゃうと早死になるでしょ
もう何でももう毒までまで食っちゃいますからね
例えば体力なんかはもういくらでも作ってやろうと思っちゃうと
男性の方々はもう歳で引退するんです
もう体クタクタ壊れちゃって
で 驚く 驚くじゃないんですかね
例えばスポーツマンなんかで
私の体力と比べると まあ私の体力がとすればもう万倍くらいありますよ
そういう人と競争するためには
私のような人間は万人ぐらいいればなんとかできますよ
それぐらい体力あるんだけど
まあ大体歳でも引退なんです
心臓が悪いわ あれやこれやもうもう持てないんで
体が なんでしょうかね
だから結局我々は生存するためにフィルタリングしますが
その情報で目的に達してないんです
逆結果になってる ほとんど目的に失敗するんです
ということは 情報のフィルターが誤作動しています
情報のフィルターは誤作動しています
じゃあ早く飛ばします
もうちょっとなんか難しくなった
そういうわけで 頭のなかに浮かないこと
1 フィルターをそのまま通る情報があります
時々人が言ったことをそのまま鵜呑みにする場合ありますよ
その場合はね 奥様もいい話がありますよという調子で言うと
すぐもう乗っちゃうんですね
しかし 誤作動ですからね
覚えておいてください
大体奥様 とっても良い話がありますと言ったところで全部ダメでしょ
なんでそこまで馬鹿になるんですかね？振り込め詐欺
振り込めやらあれ もう何言ってもなるでしょ
そこまで刺激するんですかね
一体知らない男が電話したら
もうもう孫やと思うんだからね
自分の孫の子供の声まで忘れる？ありえないです
100人喋ってる間でも
自分の子供の孫の声だけはきしっ
しっかり区別できるはずなんです
振り込め 振り込め詐欺っていうのはありえない詐欺事件なんです
不可能です 日本でできます
まあ面白い世界ですからね
で だから奥さん いい話ありますよって言われても
その通り我々は鵜呑みにするんだけど
私が言いたいのは このフィルターが誤作動していますからね
気をつけて ね フィルターが一部の情報をカットするので
変える方法は変えるんです
はい 情報が変わるんです
方法ではないんです 情報が変わるのです
だって 一部取っちゃいますからね
もう話にならない 例えば
人にお人形をあげようと思ったところで
受け取る人はお人形がよくわかります
お人形の首を折って捨てて
あ ありがとうございます
確かに受け取ります 何やってるんですかね
我々は確かに理解しましたと言うんだけど
お人形の首を折って捨ててるんです
だからくれたのは立派なお人形さんなんですけど
自分が取った途端 あ これはいらん
と取る フィルタリングする
だから本物じゃないんです
それで我々はフィルタリングして情報の一部をカットするんです
3 フィルターが一切の情報を遮断することもあります
または通らない情報もあります
時々 我々のフィルターがとにかく情報を遮断するんです
入らないことにする これではもう馬鹿になりますからね
何も聞きたくはない これもやばい
あれもやばい これも危険
あれも危険やと思ったりして
心配できない 心配できないとかね
まあ例えば中国のね いろいろ輸入する品物にはいくつかのトラブルが起きちゃったんですね
乳製品にはメラミンが入ったりとかね
で エンドウ豆には殺虫剤が入ってあったりとか
もう一つ何でしたっけ？うーん
まあ餃子にもなんとか入ってありましたとかね
そういうことであまりも厳しくなっちゃって
もう絶対もう輸入食品は信頼できませんとかね
なったりする可能性もありますね
で うなぎも食べられないんだと
もう日本産といっても
もうギリギリギリと もう台湾産のうなぎなの
私は日本産しか食わないんだよと言っていた人がわからなかったんだからね
まあ昨日かな テレビでね
なんとか夜の番組でいろいろ
あの日本のうなぎとすごい高級なうなぎと
養殖じゃなくて自然のうなぎと養殖うなぎと輸入うなぎを 3種類食べさせて
どちらでしょうか あの日本で
あの自然で その自然から取ったうなぎはどちらでしょうか？頭だけはね
偉そうなこと言ったけど
みんな選んだのは一番安い養殖輸入ものなんです
はい まあそれには脳的にはいろいろ理屈ありますから
本人たちもわかってないんですけど
で 我々はやっぱりこの結構情報を遮断するっていうね
それでうなぎには 養殖うなぎにはいろいろ化学物質入ってるよって言ったら
もう食べられなくなったと
そんなような感じで このフィルターが
フィルターが誤作動しているし
あまりにも作動するともうダメになっちゃうね
例えば家にセキュリティつけるでしょ
あまりにも厳しくセキュリティつけちゃうと
もう風も吹かなくなっちゃうんですよ
もうエラーんがなるんです
もう鳥一匹でも飛んだら大変なことになる
例えば外で何か仕事をして何か転がって大変なことになる
ものすごいエラーになったりする
だからまあ そういうふうなケースで
私たちの心の中でも情報は全く入れない
入らないということも起こります
それから入ってもわからないということもあります
フィルターのせい これは今後で例を出します
あの というわけで成り立たないんです
コミュニケーションは
頭の中の状態 感情から見ても成り立たない
フィルターから見てもコミュニケーション成り立たない
誤作動しているフィルターを通るから
情報はそのままに入りません
心からフィルターを外すことは不可能であり
危険でもあります 自分にとって有意義なものを的確に判断できるフィルターがフィルターであるならば
理想的ですが それは単純な理想なんです
自分に必要な情報だけ
幸福になる情報だけフィルタリングする的確なフィルターあればいいんだけど
それは理想だけだけど
しかし 情報にはバイアスが入る
そういうフィルターがあっても
情報にはバイアスが入ります
我々が理解するものはすべて私のバイアスが入れて理解する
他の人々もそういうことになります
これで一部は終わりました
受信者のセクション